bonsoir messieurs chez merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france patrick
mboma son look qu'est ce que vous dites
de l'ampleur du mouvement du convoi des
libertés en france
bonsoir l'ampleur du mouvement du convoi
de la liberté est à la hauteur de
l'agacement
jeudi sa partie de la population par
rapport aux mesures prises pour inciter
fortement pour répondre des termes de
des gouvernements mais en réalité pour
contraindre la partie de la population
assez qu'on appelle schéma vaccinal
c'est à dire que le gouvernement les
autorités ont considéré que toute
personne qui se prépare à des aides et
prêts à être privée de liberté est privé
de certains loisirs donc c'est ce qui
amène les français et d'autres citoyens
européens
au delà de l'ampleur du mouvement
finalement est-ce que c'est pas son
existence même qui est significative
stéphane rozès
il est significatif de façon variable
selon les pays car rappelons que le
combat de la liberté a été
initié à ottawa qu'il ya eu en ampleur
la baille qu'il a fait en pl en france
en europe pony convergences
nationales vers paris et bruxelles
évidemment chaque pays a sa singularité
culturelle et politique mais ce que
c'est signifie pour la france c'est
qu'au fond dans la continuité des gilets
jaunes le sujet de l'opposition à la
politique sanitaire et sur un terreau ou
pour une grande partie des français
au fond le mouvement des filets jaunes a
été éteint mais le divorce n'a pas
hésité accommoder d'une grande shaggy ou
derrière les questions
sigal
sanitaires il ya aussi la question de la
liberté dont de la question de la
souveraineté du peuple yann des dans
beaucoup de pop et en france
singulièrement quoi le peuple et des
ccit de la maîtrise de son destin et que
les gouvernants n'en sont plus
l'émanation il faudrait ou font le
manifester interpellé les politiques
menées derrière les gouvernants convoi
de la liberté on l'a vu qu'ils ont été
rejoints hier à paris par les
manifestants anti pas sanitaire par des
gilets jaunes aussi patrick mboyo bas
congo stéphane rozès le souligné à
l'instant on a le sentiment final
finalement d'un même mot d'ordre pour
l'ensemble de ces protestataires c'est
la défense des libertés
oui la question des libertés est au
centre de ces mouvements qu'on appelle
mouvement des gilet jaune mois quand le
convoi de la liberté
souvenez-vous au à l'origine du
mouvement des gilets jaunes il y avait
notamment la question de la hausse du
prix des carburants
nous sommes aujourd'hui plusieurs années
après la question de la hausse du prix
du carburant de la vie chère de la
difficulté à pouvoir
se déplacer se pose donc en plus de la
crise sanitaire là la question du
pouvoir d'achat ce que mon collimateur
évoqué comme les questions fiscales et
les questions sanitaires trouve une
convergence dans ce qu'on appelle
l'atteinte à la liberté la personne
personnes se sentent de plus en plus
contraintes limités dans leurs choix
dans leur façon de vivre parce que d'un
côté on est en manque de pouvoir pouvoir
faire ce qu'on veut de donner les
plaisirs où les voeux de son sont venus
voir et de l'autre part et d'autre part
on a aussi des difficultés à pouvoir
simplement jouir de sa liberté de se
mettre en danger parce qu'il faut
protéger autrui avant de penser à
protéger oui je dois d'avoir moi donc
elle comme un être et continuer de
protéger moi même si je ne ressens pas
besoin la nécessité de les protéger face
à quelque chose pourquoi je vais avoir
l'idée de penser à autrui donc on est
dans ce qu'on appelle un chamboulement
total
pendant des changements
de fond de mer philosophique du monde
occidental c'est à dire le principe de
l'individualisme donc cet échange d'un
changement de paradigme et ce changement
de paradigme amène à une contradiction
directe entre les gouvernants vis
l'élite on ne voit plus l'opposition ni
les classes intermédiaires les corps
intermédiaires on voit directement
l'équipe qui dans une démarche
convergentes peint des initiatives qui
vont à l'encontre de ce que les
populations connaissent t2 les départs à
dire le principe de l'individualisme qui
est aujourd'hui comme les encore d'où le
sentiment que la liberté n'est plus et
qu'on a connu la liberté n'a plus de
valeur qu'on pourrait lui donner d'antan
vous partager ce point de vue stéphane
rozès vue d'un fossé qui se creuse de
plus en plus entre ce qu'on appelle les
ai laissé une partie de la population
oui je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qui a été dit ce fossé a débuté au début
des années 90
quand les français notamment
ont eu le sentiment que il ne maîtrisait
plus ni eux ni les politiques
un avenir commun qu'on pourrait
construire et que le cours des choses
était conduit par le nouveau courant du
capitalisme financier depuis les choses
sont moins graves et la globalisation
économique financier en numérique les
interdépendances sanitaires ont ramené
des peuples se disant et se ressentant
dépossédés de leur destin vers des
phénomènes où effectivement ils ont le
sentiment qu'ils doivent défendre à la
fois leur identité leur liberté et des
acquis sociaux
et donc au fond dans ces grands nuages
gris
deux choses sont posés en même temps
comme sous l'ancien régime
la question fiscale est derrière la
question de la souveraineté car la
liberté
ça veut dire être individuellement et
collectivement
maître de son destin
cette dimension individuelle et
collective mais qui grêce d'abord sur
l'idée de souveraineté or le cours des
choses ou plan international le néo du
libéralisme
déstabilise tellement
l'imaginaire des peuples leur façon de
s'organiser selon leurs us et coutumes
qu'effectivement sous des formes
différentes
au travers du club il n'y a je dirais
une grande défiance à l'égard de ceux
qui devraient être nos vernon et qui
semblent eux lui par d'autres logiques
alors on était à deux mois de la
présidentielle à patrick mboyo bas congo
cette large mobilisation quel impact est
ce qu'elle peut avoir sur le scrutin
présidentiel peut être déjà sur la
participation et ce sera le mot de la
fin
oui la participation va être une
question vraiment à décrypter lors de
ces élections puisque cette mobilisation
qui est d'une ampleur tout à fait
inattendu
va conduire à ce que les gens puissent
se manifester clairement concrètement
mais c'est possible d'une façon
politique au niveau des urnes pour
défendre leur liberté comme ça vient des
prêts dit tout à l'heure au nouveau plan
national mais aussi leur souveraineté au
plan européen et le choix sera tout à
fait particulier à ce niveau là ce sera
vraiment à surveiller puisque le reste a
cédé ce type de maintenant on pas
seulement au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale au niveau de l'elysée mais
surtout au niveau de la commission
européenne à bruxelles ainsi que du
conseil européen et c'est là que l'enjeu
sera tout à fait particulier a observé
par rapport à la mobilisation les gens
ne viendront plus que pour des questions
nationales mais aussi pour les questions
européennes sae international
merci beaucoup à tous les deux mais
c'est d'avoir participé à cet échange
stéphane rozès politologue président du
cape patrick mboyo bakambu aux
chercheurs en droit public à
l'université paris saclay